well we all starved for action after the
pandemic what the co-stars simply too
good to miss or can the box office
Bonanza of John Wick chapter 4 be
credited entirely to Keanu Reeves
[Music]
Keanu Reeves is no stranger to the
action thriller genre the actor broke
with his early career type casting when
he starred in 1999's The Matrix which
was written and directed by the
wachowskis The Matrix spawned its own
franchise with two sequels in 2003 and a
fourth film in 2021 all featuring reason
is now iconic role as hacker turns cyber
Freedom Fighter Neo however in the Years
following the Matrix Reeves career hits
something of a slump things changed on
the first John Wick film arrived in 2014
and Reeves triumphantly returned to
being an action star the film stars
Keanu is a titular ex assassin who comes
out of retirement to get revenge on the
gangsters who killed his puppy and stole
his car it proved to be the perfect
vehicle to relaunch Reed's career as an
action hero
people keep asking if I'm back and I
haven't really had an answer
but now yeah I'm thinking I'm back as
opposed to the effects heavy fight
scenes of The Matrix John Wick reshaped
action films by emphasizing the use of
practical effects and flowing
choreography this trend continued into
the film's production Style with
director's Chad stahelski and David
Leach deploying long takes I kept the
action clear and in focus with an
emphasis on the stunt work this involved
extensive rehearsals and pre-production
planning but it all culminated in an
action film that stood out and
established a unique franchise
the first John MC film did well at the
box office accruing 86 million dollars
against a fairly small budget of 20
million dollars its surprise success
gave Keanu Reeves and directed Chad
stahelski the opportunity to reunite for
the sequel John Wick chapter 2 released
in 2017. this time the film's budget
increased but produced even greater
returns at the box office while
receiving even more favor from critics
even though many critics appreciated how
neatly tied up the first John Wick film
was the further expansion of the
universe proved fruit form in 2019 John
Wick chapter 3 Parabellum was released
in theaters following keanu's character
on the run after his excommunication
from the high table put him in the
sights of seemingly every assassin in
the world meanwhile spin also put into
motion as early as 2017 including an
upcoming peacock mini-series titled the
Continental centered on the backstory of
the eponymous underworld hotel with Mel
Gibson set to Star these days it can be
quite challenging for an original Ip to
find a place for itself among franchises
but Keanu Reeves feels that audiences
are picking up on the film's
authenticity in 2019 Reeves spoke with
collider talking about how the films are
very easy to watch highlighting the
thrill of movie going that the John Wick
franchise exploits
the 2010s are an era of reinvention for
many film genres have become stale
Jordan peels gets out revolutionize the
horror genre while directors like Greta
Gerwig and Olivia Wilde created a new
generation of iconic coming-of-age
movies for teens to fall in love with in
a similar vein the first John Wick felt
like a return to form for a once great
genre in anticipation of John Wick
chapter 3 Parabellum Rolling Stone were
called the first film success as the
beginning of what would become the
seriously bad crazy go For Broke open
world action flick franchise of the 21st
century they emphasized how dearly
missed action films like John Wick were
in certain ways John Wick calls back to
the days of Sylvester Stallone as John
Rambo tearing through the jungle or even
Bruce Willis as John McLean heroically
saving his marriage and nakatomi Plaza
from terrorists in Die Hard
together have a few laughs much of this
Nostalgia and love have to do with John
Wick as a franchise remaining loyal to
highly choreographed fight scenes
incredibly complex stunts gruesome yet
entertaining violence and a smorgasbord
of great action movie influences
in the 2020s it's proven hard to have a
successful theater run if your movie
isn't part of a franchise even
critically acclaimed directors like
Damien chazelle or Robert Eggers have
seen their theatrical epics falter at
the box office this was the case with
their films Babylon and the northmen
it's much easier for success to land
with sequels or spin-offs such as 2023's
Creed 3 or fan service favorites like
Marvel Spider-Man no way home it's a
problem that poses a dilemma for movie
theater chains The Hollywood Reporter
reveals that many theaters
underperformed in 2022 despite big
releases like black panther wakanda
forever and Avatar the way of water the
latter of which grossed over 2 billion
dollars although things have greatly
improved since the start of the kobit 19
pandemic it's hard to attract movie fans
to the theater when so many high-profile
releases are simultaneously released to
streaming or available within a few
months of their theatrical release still
not every movie studio can Bank on a
word by mouth hit like the recent Best
Picture Winner everything everywhere all
at one months but this is where John
Wick chapter 4 likely benefits with a
studio like Lionsgate backing it it's
hard for anybody to be oblivious to the
release of the latest John Wick
Adventure thanks to marketing the
attachment of a likable star and the
overall popularity of the previous three
films and the franchise
while one can credit a lot of the box
office success of John Wick to its
originality as a franchise and a sheer
thrill of watching films like it on a
big screen no one can deny that at the
center of it all lies one secret weapon
Keanu Reeves
that's cool that's kind Reeves is even
more talked about than his ex-hipman
character on the internet with many
sharing stories about their encounters
with the actor in public whether it's
donating his salary to crew members on
his films or going out of his way to
give autographs to fans who are too
nervous to ask him it's hard not to fall
in love with Reeves as if there wasn't
enough proof of Reeves awesome nurse and
humility the actor seems modest about
the love his fans have for him recently
telling people that he really
appreciates the Goodwill sent his way
online
the John Wick franchise went on
something of a Hiatus due to force
production delays resulting from the
covid-19 pandemic John Wick chapter 4
didn't even enter principal photography
until the summer of 2021 where the
release intended for May 2022 that
release window for chapter 4 was
complicated by the impending release of
top gun Maverick on the same day in 2022
which resulted in it being pushed back
to early 2023. by the time chapter 4
finally premiered in late March 2023
fans have been waiting more than four
years for the next installment the
release of chapter 4 and 2023 is also
coinciding with an easier return to the
theater for many during the covid-19
pandemic lots of people felt hesitant to
return to the movies especially when
many studios released films on streaming
services shortly after their theatrical
release is not entirely in place of it
however an action movie with a big star
seems to be just a project to woo even
the most pandemic cautious moviegoers
back into those seats
it's no secret that Keanu Reeves and
Laurence Fishburne make a dynamite Duo
on the big screen the two actors first
appeared together in 1999's The Matrix
with Keanu playing the lead role of Neo
and Fishburn giving an iconic
performance as Morpheus the human Rebel
who introduces Neo to the truth behind
the dystopian future he lives in the two
reprise their roles in The Matrix
Reloaded and The Matrix Revolutions
though they spent many years apart
following the temporary ends to The
Matrix trilogy while Keanu returns as
Neo in The Matrix resurrections
Fishburne notably did not reappear as
Morpheus he was in Stereo plays with
Watchman actor Yaya Abdul Mateen II as
an artificial intelligence designed
after fishburn's deceits character the
two have starred together in the John
Wick franchise ever since John Wick's
chapter 2 where Fishburne debuted as a
Barry King the leader of an underground
spy organization allied with Reeves
titular character Fishburne returned in
John Wick's chapter 3 Parabellum as well
as John Wick chapter 4 which should
satisfy the Matrix fans who've missed
the actor's appearance in the Matrix
resurrections
after all man has to look his best when
it's time to get married
or buried
a new face appearing in John Wick
chapter 4 may also represent a big draw
for audiences to see it on the big
screen it was reported in 2021 that
Japanese British pop artist Arena soyama
will be making her feature film debut in
the latest John Wick film sawyama's
music career particularly took off in
2020 with the release of her album
sawayama which was lauded by critics for
its nostalgic factors and ambition in
the pop sphere so ayama has continued to
collaborate with notable artists like
Charlie XCX and Elton John leading up to
a 2022 sophomore album hold the girl
given the aesthetic of her music and her
performance in music videos for her
songs she was an easy choice to play the
role of Akira in John Wick chapter 4.
according to director Chad stachelski
sawayama seems right out of an anime in
an interview with enemy the role of
Akira takes advantage of this even with
very little screen time in the film
Akira is a daughter of the Osaka
Continentals manager Koji shimazu Koji
protects John Wick from the high tables
and forces and ultimately dies in The
ensuing conflict fans of sawayama's
music will be thrilled to see her in the
action film and her audience will
definitely buy movie tickets to see it
unfortunately the latest installment in
the John Wick franchise is Not Without
Tragedy in March 2023 only days after
his Premiere in London actor Lance
Reddick sadly passed away the actor Nova
his performances in the wire and lost
was a staple of the John Wick franchise
since the very first film where he
debuted Sharon the concierge of the
continental and a close Confidant of its
manager Winston while all of his John
Wick co-stars have been vocaled in their
grief Keanu Reeves paid special tribute
to Reddick calling him a beautiful
special person in an interview with CNN
and donning a blue ribbon in remembrance
of the actor other eulogies poured in
from franchise director Chad staholski
as well as Radix former collaborators
David Simon and James gern John Wick
chapter 4 won't be the last time
audiences will have the opportunity to
watch Lance Reddick perform posthumously
the actor has many future projects lined
up including the John Wick spin-off
ballerina the Percy Jackson and the
Olympians TV adaptation on Disney plus
and the 2023 remake of Men Can't Jump
however John Wick chapter 4 is
nonetheless being a great opportunity
for fans to head to the movie theater
and see one of reddick's final
performances as the iconic Continental
concierge many moviegoers are flocking
to see John Wick chapter 4. purely
because of its Stellar reviews the
previous three entries in the franchise
were all well received by critics but
chapter 4 clearly raised the bar when
the eyed of the Guardian showered the
fourth installment with praise writing
you expect that the stunts and fight
choreography of a John Wick film will be
top tier but even by the standards of
the past week outings this is remarkable
Richard Brody of the New Yorker labeled
it by far the best of the four films a
Manola dark is of the New York Times
called it pure eye-popping body shaking
transporting entertainment the film is
not without its detractors such as a
reviewer for consequence who criticized
the film's somatic low points and lack
of coherence but still found lots to
praise about its spectacle but by and
large the critics love it it earned a 94
on Rotten Tomatoes based on more than
280 reviews
the geometry franchise has slowly become
one of the biggest original IPS of the
2010s nevertheless John Wick chapter 4
seems to be the end for now with
director Chad stahlski telling The
Hollywood Reporter that he and Keanu
Reeves plan to give John Wick a rest
though he admits it would always be
possible for him and Keanu to have
discussions that lead to another film
for now seeing John Wick's chapter 4 is
an opportunity that fans of the
franchise shouldn't miss out on however
the franchise isn't going anywhere Anna
dayamas is set to start with Rooney a
ballerina assassin played by unity
Phelan in John Wick's chapter 3. in a
spin-off film titled ballerina currently
set to be released in 2024 Keanu Reeves
Lance Reddick and Ian McShane are all
confirmed to be reprising their roles
from the primary John Wick films and
ballerina which itself May Branch out
into his own film franchise if it goes
over well with audiences right now
chances seem slim for a fifth John Wick
Raves and stahlski seem to be content
with leaving the franchise behind while
the box office success of the latest
film as a studio thinking otherwise it
all comes down to keanu's interest in
reprising the role
you were working again
no I just sorting some stuff out
foreign
[Music]